oui je pense qu'on l'a vu d'ailleurs
dans les différents extraits je pense
que tu es le mec qui porte le mieux la
calvitie dans le paf
c'est même si le ch a pas le choix
maintenant mais le souvenir de cheveux
c'est pas toi
donc on s'est amusé à faire des montages
de people de chroniqueurs avec une
calvitie pour ceux qui ont des cheveux
parions qu'on a pris stéphane bern
regarde voilà stéphane bern voilà une
canne mais c'est pas mal encore à
l'école bref c'est pas mal ça reste la
pierre jean salençon regard des dix
victimes ça lui va peut-être mieux ça
ouais il peut pas de piège et au hockey
le mec dam un chroniqueur d'allemagne
conclut d'affaires conclut ce qu'elle
veut sa peau la réf
regardez laurent delahousse il ouais
mais parce qu'ils les primes trop avec
ses cheveux on a vraiment voulu l'unique
et sa mère on va pas il est beau gosse
et on s'est dit on va le défoncer ouais
mec comme ça ils ouvrent beaucoup moins
sexy
les frères bogdanoff
malgré qu'ils aient ou non mais couper
la tête qui arrivent et les bogdanoff on
a abusé c'est déjà beaucoup
euh non mais c'est vrai voilà mieux
comme ça je trouve mais c'est vrai que
tu me demandes si wes alors on va
limites qu'il faut soigner le mal par le
mal façons tu penses qu'ils ont rien
fait c'est dingue
alors on a alors je sens que pour moi on
s'est appliqué non mais je te jure que
toi ils se sont vraiment appliqué il a
mis du temps le gardien là ça y est là
tous ces pistes seraient keller voilà on
est ouvert jusqu'à 3 heures du matin
c'est d'andijan 16 ans ça lui va sonner
tout lui va
on a on à laurent baffie vous savez
pourquoi je fais deux implants parce
qu'un jour je me suis rasé
j'avais pas une tête de choses sinon je
n'aurais pas fait mais c'est que ça
devait y perd bien non et bah ça
n'allait pas vous trouvez qu'on dirait
bien sûr la cicos et ian mc ledenon
avéré plus bruce willis un mec qui monte
et julie sont prises et bruce est unique
c'est très beau à léona abanda bernard
montiel
en fait il faut pas les idées faut pas
laisser sur le côté ça qui est beau non
ça c'est bon je crois qu'il faut y avait
meilleur pour la fin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout lui va
ces quatre c4 bignac annoncé leygnac
sérignac
c'est insupportable pour moi j'ai
attaqué j'ai une qualité de cheveux
aussi par leur dire l affiche de touche
pas à mon pote 2035